[Musique]
jean christophe averty eu les api est la
principale cause de destruction de la
culture télévisuelle
car ce pistolet qui qui servent d'abord
et la liberté
non c'est un service manque total un
enfermement
au total le rapport est un pistolet
qu'on a mis dans la main un spectateur
pour tirer sur l'écran qui lui tire
également des idioties sol
c'était un instrument défense mais en
mitraillant et en brisant le spectacle
continue il ne peut plus avoir à la fin
d'une soirée que des fragments
d'ignorance et l'empreinte connaissance
un spectacle se jugent complètement je
regarde très peu la télévision comme si
quand je n'ai pas des blessures qui
passe je vous dis franchement elle
n'intéresse guère radio vous n'avez même
pas y avait plus longtemps mais quand
j'ai choisi un programme lorsqu'il est
bon ou mauvais je le regarde jusqu'au
bout ça c'est le théâtre nom de taille
et lorsque je veux me puisse faire un
jugement complet sur ce programme mais
chip que cela arrange pas ça certes une
petite pique que ma petit pantin devant
un écran qui me dit fut saisie de ces
inepties
je n'ai rien dans la tête qu'un miroir
brisé donc le zappeur et d'une chose
effroyable maintenant la multiplicité
des chaînes que vous dit mme bernard
être un choix possible
c'est un non choix futurs car plusieurs
chaînes muayad yeux pour regarder chaque
chaîne
les gens ne regardent plus rien et je
suis content certains soirs quand je
rentre tard vers disons quand j'entre e
tour pardonnez moi alors du print yb
entre 20h et 20h30 paris et plein de
bagnols il ya plein de gens dans les
rues qui circulent il ne regarde en rien
à la télé vie
ils sont heureux parce qu'ils montrent
maintenant une fois express ont pu
rentrer chez eux pour voir le prime time
est un devoir sacré filon des français
sur les greens de stoneham et sauveur
une culture générale
on la rime chez soi à 10 heures et à ce
moment là on commence à regarder quelque
chose qui nous apprend quelques jours
alors de prison cultivés dans des oeufs
alors vous êtes contre l'access prime
time
oui c'est tout lier ces mots dérisoire
dérivé de l'anglais tous et marketing
tous ces politiques tous et non en inc
tout ce jargon structuraliste ou non
mais ça va pas complètement segal savait
pas partout de culture générale
aujourd'hui la petite boîte noire
les parts de marché mais tout ce fourbi
arabe
tina cdu bavard qui n'a d'ailleurs en
voit les conséquences
maintenant aujourd'hui